hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game that just happened or
rather incredible games that just
happened I'm gonna show you two games in
this video now one will be Daniel dubo
versus Alexander grishuk and the other
one you probably already know what it is
of course it is
and this is the one I'm gonna show you
first as a lot of you have been asking
over the the years just kidding over the
months that have passed whereas dubo why
isn't he playing anywhere as well I know
how much you guys enjoy his game so this
is a a game that happened from the uh I
believe it's around seven or uh first
round that was played on day two of the
world rapid Team Championship so let's
check it out uh you your mind will just
explode while while watching this so
let's check it out uh the themes are
alpha x links uh lint versus freedom and
Daniel has the white pieces he opens
with Pawn to D4 we have Knight to F6 by
Alexander grishock Knight to F3 we have
Ponte D5 and sorry Punta D5 and C4 we
have E6 so a standard Queen's Gambit
declined is on the board and G3 Dube of
opts for the uh for the Catalan opening
of the Queen's Gambit decline with
Bishop D7 Bishop to G2 and now both
players Castle so castles castles and
the D caprese and C4 now this is the the
mainst of the line that you could
possibly have in in the Catalan and many
many have played this Magnus had this
position against ding I think in three
games being even defeated him with white
in one of the games uh many many players
had is Nakamura played it against the
Anand um Wesley still played against
Vladimir kramnik uh you you know you you
name a player they've played this
position look here Queen to C2 just
preparing to capture back the pawn on
the A6 preparing Pawn to B5 and of
course Pawn to A4 with Bishop to D7 now
getting ready to counter white strong
light core Bishop Wood Bishop to C6 and
here uh Queen characters and C4 is the
most common move and pretty much
everyone plays it in all of those games
that being played against Magnus always
Queen captures and C4 was played even in
the one where ding defeated Magnus but
here we have Bishop to G5 it's a fairly
rare move it's been played uh well not
all that many times but one player who
does play it with white interestingly is
Alexander grishuk himself so a Dube of
playing some Mind Games here uh Bishop
to C6 of course countering Duo's strong
bashopen G2 and now Rook to D1 we have
Pawn to B5 and the bishop captures an F6
with Bishop captures and Knight to C3 so
again nothing new here we have Queen to
E8 uh adding more Firepower to this
diagonal and also getting the Queen off
of the d8 square and now okay you could
choose E4 but you could also play D5
right away again it has been played
before we have Bishop captures by uh
grishock a captures on B5 and now we
have Bishop captures and C3 there is a
game where eight characters and B5 was
played uh on Ocean versus a
dating J relating J defeater with this
eight captures on B5 move in 2019 in the
women's world team championship Astana
Kazakhstan but here we have Bishop
captures on C3 and it is now as of move
14 that we have a completely new game
and this is basically where our Journey
Begins okay you would expect it be
captures on C3 or queen captures on C3
but not when Daniel is playing he goes
Knight G5 he threatens to Checkmate on
H7 and okay it's a fine Swish and sug if
we've ever seen one we have Pawn to G6
you could also play Pawn to F5 but maybe
it ruins your uh position a little too
much and also the E6 Pawn will be
weakened topon to G6 and now Queen
captures on C3 so by doing this uh you
know in between move dubo now gains
control of this diagonal and already you
have to wonder what uh what is happening
what if Rook to D4 is played and the
Knight captures on H7 Rook to H4 are you
just getting checkmated uh is is there
even a way out of this well it is
Alexander grishuk he's playing and of
course grishuk finds the answer Queen
captures on B5 not the movie you'd
expect because all the action is
happening on the king side but the main
point of the move is Queen to B3 of
course you want to offer a queen trade
and now what I've been wondering is that
uh yeah when I first saw this position
and I I came back home and I you know I
turned on the the broadcast of the world
rapid Championship they were pretty much
at this position and I thought Rook D4
now is Queen to B3 the solution to Rook
to D4 and the the story of Rook to D4 is
basically why I'm making this video so
it was not played but I will just show
you what happens if it is played and
dubo spent quite a lot of time uh as it
is a rapid game he spent some six
minutes or maybe even seven minutes on
this move now uh the idea is not Queen
to B3 it seems like this solves all of
your problems but not really because
Knight captures an E6 uh gives puts a
lot of trouble in Black's position now
of course you can't capture with the
bishop the rook and A8 would hang so
you're gonna capture with the F Pawn and
now you're gonna get Rook captures on D5
and okay we trade Queen's capture
captures and now you you're going to
play captures on D5 or not it's not
really all that great to capture The
Rook but if you do then Bishop captures
will deliver a check for the Rook on A8
and once the king moves You're Gonna
Play Bishop captures an A8 okay it's the
exact same material but black spawn
structure is uh messed up and the white
Rook would make easy work of those
stranded pawns so what you do play after
Rook to D4 is again why I'm making this
video and that of course is Bishop
captures on G2 again not not a move
you'd expect here because now Knight
captures on H7 what how do you defend
against Rook H4 I mean isn't this just
over not really if you okay if you
capture then you just get checkmated
that's not really an issue you could
walk with the queen but then you're down
a queen the idea behind this um uh
Knight captures on H7 move is Pawn to E5
that's how you defend you block the
Queen's diagonal and now you play Rook
to H4 of course you defend your knight
and black just calmly Retreats the
bishop and okay black snatched upon here
Knight captures an f8 King captures an
f8 and now Rook to A5 attacking the
queen queen to C6 now threatening
Checkmate and now Rook to h8 with the
check King to G7 now Queen captures an
E5 with check luckily the queen on C6
isn't just threatening Checkmate also
supports the F6 to pawn to F6 Queen to
E7 with check King captures on h8 and
now Queen to f8 to check and you will
have a draw by repetition doesn't really
matter where what the black king does
even King the H6 will be met with Queen
to f8 to check and you cannot go to the
fifth rank or I mean even if you could
you probably wouldn't want to King H7
and here we would see a draw by
perpetual so this is a white dubo was
calculating so much here uh probably
contemplating this Rook to D4 move but
in the end he decided to go for uh
before I show you that I just want to
tell you what the the computer
recommends the computer computer
recommends Rook A5 and okay we trade
down into the send game Queen B3 Queen
captures on B3 C captures on B3 and now
Knight captures an E6 that's computer's
idea of course it's pretty pretty much
the same like the variation we've
discussed you cannot capture because of
Bishop captures and A8 you're going to
have to play F captures now we're going
to see roof captures and D5 or even
better this Rook captures on D5 and
after Pawn captures You're Gonna Play
Bishop captures on D5 with checking G7
Bishop characters and the exact same
position arises as uh in the line that
we've discussed but not to do both and
this is why I like Dubose games all that
much he doesn't play the move that you
know okay maybe brings you the victory
and is very difficult to calculate he
doesn't play the absolute strongest move
recommended by the engine but he finds a
way to complicate things sort of a human
move but not really not even Knight
captures and E6 he goes for the straight
Knight captures on F7 and now what this
allows and something that Michael tal
always taught us uh you know on uh how
to attack give your opponent as many
chances to make a mistake as possible
you might get the exact same position as
in the other lines only try to you
should always try to get the exact same
position but in the most complicated way
imaginable okay now you could play cap
the king captures uh in the game we have
you know you could play Rook captures in
the game we have King characters both
moves are fine it all depends on how you
continue playing and now Rook to A5 with
winter B3 and now double just trades
Queen captures Pawn captures and now
Rook D captures on E5 so uh similar but
not quite the same and here uh Sasha
should play e captures on D5 but just by
playing this Knight captures on F7 move
uh dubov confused Sasha uh just you know
enough nuts to capture this the point is
you should capture gold Bishop captures
on D5 and after King the E7 Bishop
capture 78 of course uh
okay I'm not playing this this is too
good but there is the C6 move and this
is the move you have to find in order to
play that now the bishop is trapped here
and it's not clear how to get the
bishopod bishop to B7 uh you're gonna
play Rook to d8 and there's never a good
way okay you could play Bishop captures
on A6 but it's not uh nothing
spectacular so now Rook to A3 you want
to play Rook capture some B3 to defend
your bishop and now Knights the D7 uh
Bishop captures and C6 Knights the C5
defends both of the pawns and if Rook to
A5 you're gonna play Rook to D1 Chuck
King moves and King D6 defends uh the
Knight attacks the bishop and black is
very much in the game with a very very
active King so this is how you should
play it but Sasha played King to E7 and
now dubov gets uh the play Rook to D3
now offer attacks the rook and A8 and
threatens the pawn on B3 and both of
them were already very very low on time
here Rook to A7 and now just Rook
captures on B3 and you get this position
the material is the same but it's a
better against the Knight and of course
if there's play on both sides of the
board of course you know that a bishop
is a little bit better than a Knight
Knight Knight to D7 and now Bishop to H3
the uh E6 Pawn is weak and of course the
dubo will hone in on that weakness and
another thing of course if you're only
starting with chess you can notice that
black has four Pawn islands and white
has two Pawn Island so it's much better
to have two Pawn Islands than four Pawn
Islands uh it's just easier to pick up
the pawns so here we have Rook to B8
offering a rook trade and double just
the trade we have captors characters
captures and now he goes after the
weakness that is the E6 Pawn Rook to E5
and okay Rook to B7 goes after the B2
Pawn Rook captures an E6 with check with
King 38 and now Rook to F6 now you have
to be a little bit careful because okay
the bishop controls D7 and C8 if Rook
Rook to f8 check happens you know that
the Knight might fall so you don't want
to move the Rook away from the B file
the real characters on B2 is fine that
is what Sasha goes for now Rook to F7
dubo limits the movement of Sasha's King
and waits for his next uh well move or
mistake and you could play a lot of
moves here
a5h6h5 but in the game Rook captures an
E2 was played the point is that um okay
let's you continue Pawn to A5 because
now you definitely realize that it's a
race if Ponte A5 dubo would play Rook
captures in H7 if Ponte A4 Bishop to E6
now a guard the A2 square and if A3 just
King to G2 and now you don't have A2
because if you play A2 there's Rook to
AJ to check King to E7 attacks the
bishop but it doesn't matter Bishop
captures an A2 and that gets the rid of
the pawn will captures and Rook captures
Knight and you have four pawns against
two of course uh well if nothing crazy
happens should be a winning position
okay Rook captures an E2 it's three
pawns against two but still those two
are weak the these three are connected
uh excellent winning chances for dubo so
of course nothing uh uh great for Sasha
there so he plays Rook captures on E2 uh
one thing this does is that now if a
race occurs Bishop to E6 is no longer an
option so duboff plays Rook characters
on H7 and now Pawn to A5 we have rooked
the G7 Now Pawn to A4 and dubo now finds
Bishop to F1 uh and how do you continue
the point is okay you could play A3 but
again do both sort of Tricks Sasha or
maybe Sasha was still trying to win the
game A3 is just not enough to win
because after Bishop captures an A2 you
will also pick off the Knight Rook G
checking the seven Rook captures mb8 and
you okay you get a queen with checking
G2 and it's still a rook and Bishop
three pawns versus a queen and two Pawn
so of course a queen is stronger but uh
with the seconds on the clock for both
of them it will be easier to to
coordinate a bishop and Rogue because
once you put the bishop on this diagonal
the Black Wing can never even deliver a
single check and The Rook will start
harassing the king so but again it is
the best way to draw this but as usual
dubov uh makes his opponent work a very
hard for his meal and Rook to E8 is the
move that Sasha chooses but now Rook
captures on G6 we have Knight to the D7
and the bishop to B5 by dubov uh
attacking the pawn here uh Sasha plays
Rook to E4 defends the pawn and now the
position is completely winning toyan
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the absolute best move for doomov
while I give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh wild idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is of
course Rook the G8 with check uh dubov
played it and he was in this position on
move 34 that uh Sasha grishuk resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here the problem is if you play
Rook to E8 then of course you you can
just trade row captures King captures
and Bishop captures on A4 you're up to
Pawns of course in a completely winning
position and on the other hand after
Rook to G8 check if you go King to E7
then the point is Rook the G7 with check
and now the Knight will hang you you're
gonna move the king somewhere doesn't
really matter where if you play here
then it even comes with checks so King
F6 will captures on D7 and the pawn is
too far away for you to do anything
about it A3 will be met with Rook D2 and
that's all there is Europe Europe a
piece completely winning so uh
brilliantly done by dubov and it's also
one of the reasons why I know you guys
enjoyed Duo's games so much it's exactly
this position where this uh first like a
movie like Knight to G5 a beautiful
season 2 that allows him to grab hold of
this diagonal and die after Queen
captures on B5 simply the possibility of
Rook to D4 and all of these variations
that you had to calculate but the dubov
avoids it even though it's such a
complicated lines uh but he just you
know finds a way out of all of these
moves out of Rook to D4 Rook to a rook
to A5 Rook to D4 Knight captures and F7
Knight captures an E6 Knight captures an
H7 he found the one that uh forced Sasha
to burn a lot of his time in the in the
end you know got him to to make that one
mistake that allowed the duboff to win
the game so brilliantly done by dubov
and now we are continuing on to the uh a
game that is even shorter and even
crazier and it is the one between
Richard Rapport and Etienne bakra also
uh on the same team and the cool thing
is okay I'm not going to mention it I
could spoil it a little bit so let's
just check out the game first and then
we're gonna discuss it uh Rapport has
the white pieces and he opens with E4 we
have Pawn to E6 and now Pawn to D3 also
I've been using this quite a lot against
the French lately also funny
Etienne being French playing the French
uh uh you know very cool uh I've been
playing it quite a lot uh you know
instead of Pawn to D4 because it's it
just uh weirds out the players with the
black pieces because everyone who plays
the French is so used to having this
Pawn on D4 and later undermining it with
C5 that is just I I guess it's weird for
them to play it with Pawn to D3 and okay
we have Pawn to D5 Knight to D2 and now
Pawn to C5 and now usually this Pawn
will be attacking the D4 Pawn but not
here Pawn to G3 we have Knight to C6 and
now Bishop to G2 we have Knight to F6
and now Knight G2 F3 you could also
include a queen T2 move if you want uh
before this but this is basically your
standard setup you will have D3 E4 the
knights will be here the bishop will be
fine cathode you will Castle play Queen
T2 and you will always have a great game
the point is that if black ever wants to
grab more space in the center with the
D4 then you get everything you've
dreamed of from the position you will
play E5 and if Knight to D5 you will
play A4 so those are the two moves that
will give you an excellent game black
will of course Play Bishop E7 castles
but the point is you will get the C4
Square for your knight and by playing
Point A4 you've prevented Pawn to B5 you
have the Knight on C4 pretty much for
the rest of the game the Knight on F3
you have firm grip on the E5 square and
at some point black will maybe try to
under mine it with F6 but your your
position is great and you will enjoy
playing this so if you're annoyed by
playing the standard uh D4 against
French maybe try this but okay Bishop to
E7 we have Castles by both players and
now we have Rook D1 but also after
seeing this game uh you know uh I see I
have to be a lot more careful than I
usually am and here the standard movie
spawned to B5 grabbing more space on the
queen side because why not why it allows
it or even Queen to C7 uh we have the
slow H6 by Etienne and now comes Pawn to
A4 and this is now a new move so now
already as of move 9 we have a
completely new game we have Pawn to B6
uh sort of a conservative way of playing
uh playing the position but of course
Etienne knows what he's doing Pawn to E5
and now not the Knight is the D7 but
Knight to H7 instead with some ideas of
maybe Knight to G5 onto H4 stopping that
and now Queen to C7 we have Fawn to C3
and now Pawn to F6 of course the black
will always play this to undermine the
E5 Pawn uh e captures on F6 Knight
captures on F6 and now Pawn to D4 uh we
have Bishop to D6 now uh Rapport is uh
already seeing what's what's going on
here the the G3 Pawn is being threatened
The Rook is very nicely placed on this
semi-openf file the Knight is going to
come to G4 to put more pressure on F2 so
is there something to worry about here
obviously not Knight to B3 Knight to F1
is a bit safer you know just adding more
protection to G3 but it goes Knight to
B3 he wants to prepare Pawn to A5 and
now comes Knight to G4 just putting even
more pressure on the on the white king
Bishop to E3 and here uh Etienne goes
for it we have Bishop captures and G3
and it doesn't look like much I mean
okay you get two points for the piece
but where is the actual attack uh F
captures and G3 Queen captures and G3
and now comes uh well Knight beta D2 is
um uh what you have to play but in order
to find this move you have to see what
is Black's threat and also this is one
of the principles uh you could use also
from the pre
always give your opponent as many
possibilities to make a mistake as you
can and here a report makes the mistake
he plays Queen to E2 and now the
position is completely winning for 18
but only if you can see why so feel free
to pause the video and find the win for
18 while I give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on uh always uh
you know looking at that least active
piece and looking how it can end the
game and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is a rook captures
on F3 this is what uh Etienne played and
he was in this position on move 18 that
alright resigned to the game as there is
nothing more to be done here so what can
you do uh of course you cannot capture
with the bishop and if you capture with
the queen now you see that this diagonal
opens up and that is all there is to it
Queen page to check King to F1 and now
Bishop to A6 check and the black king
has no moves you have to block with the
queen that's obviously silly and if you
play Rook T2 you would very much uh
welcome Bishop counters on E2 but now
Rook to f8 and there's uh no move well
so many skewers from all sides The Queen
Is Lost The Rook is lost and there's I
mean whatever you play you just
eliminate the White Queen the white rook
and the it'd be silly to even try to
make a move here with white there just
isn't one uh so of course the Rapport
Solace and after these beautiful root
captures and F3 we can even show it in
slow motion there you have it uh it was
in this position that he resigned I mean
what what a game uh so yeah uh you know
a mind-blowing position in the in the
dubo grishuk also a beautiful miniature
here by bayatian so hope you enjoyed
both games if you have any other games
that you think that should be covered uh
use hashtag suggestion in the comments
and I will uh do my best to go over them
uh so yeah those were the games hope you
guys enjoyed it I would like to thank
rajashri chaoduri Robert Bloom Andrew
woolly an anonymous person in the girls
need chess
festival.org.org.gg for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes uh
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day